we know more about how the natural world
works than ever before it's kind of a
perfect storm for nature inspired
innovation during Hurricane Katrina
you would have thought that the live
oaks on st. Charles Street would have
died when actually only four out of over
seven hundred trees died why is that
well the trees it turns out the whole
thing is a blueprint for how to survive
darkens their trunk is spiraled so they
flex in the wind and their branches are
spiraled so they flex and their leaves
when wind hits them they curl into the
shape of a Fibonacci sequence which
allows the wind to flow through with
minimal friction so that the Leafs don't
get torn off easily and even more
importantly under the ground its roots
are actually entwined with the roots of
the trees next to it so when a hurricane
hits a live oak in New Orleans it's not
hitting one tree it's hitting a whole
community so perhaps in rebuilding New
Orleans to be more or hurricane
resilient instead of our individual pier
foundations we may think about
foundations that have horizontal
components that twine together with the
foundations of the buildings next door
so that you've got the wind hitting an
entire community of buildings and not
just one architects and engineers are
beginning to explore this in other
places they're starting to think like a
live oak tree to design buildings and
homes
they're safer and more resilient for
more episodes of think like a tree
subscribe to the wired Channel